de son fils tombés au mali dominique
protin a conservé des souvenirs et
quelques portraits c'est une dernière
photo qu'alexandre a envoyé quelques
jours avant l'incident
c'était le 25 novembre 2019 quelque part
au mali treize soldats français meurent
dans un accident d'hélicoptère alors
qu'ils mènent une opération contre un
groupe armé jihadistes l'adjudant
alexandre protin avait 33 ans dix années
d'engagement dans l'armée pour son père
il n'est pas mort pour rien
si aujourd'hui on vit tranquillement
voilà on va pas revivre ces attentats on
a c'est grâce à tous ces hommes qui
qu'il a au combat tu empêches le
terrorisme le djihadisme d'arriver
jusque chez à nos portes quoi
une semaine après l'accident la france
avait rendu hommage à ses traits soldats
tombés au combat
parmi eux se trouvait aussi le capitaine
pierre bockel lui effectué à 28 ans sa
quatrième mission au mali au moment de
l'accident pour son père jean marie
bockel ancien secrétaire d'état à la
défense la fin de l'opération barkan est
difficile à accepter ce départ du mali
sont morts nos enfants comment voulez
vous que ça nous laisse indifférent
puisque des choses auraient pu se passer
différents toute façon nous avions
vocation à partir
cette décision elle était inéluctable
je la déplore mais je la comprends l'
annonce officielle du retrait français
dominique protin l'a suivi de chez lui
il reste convaincu que si la france
quitte le mali elle ne doit pas pour
autant abandonné la région on peut pas
partir comme ça je n'ai donné raison à
tous hétéros reset faisait jadis quand
je vais continuer à montrer qu'on est là
et qu'on se bat quoi je dirais que c'est
pas y s'est pas terminée et c'est pas
gagné pour eux en neuf ans d'opération
53 soldats français sont morts au combat
ou sahel